this usb right here costs more than ten
thousand dollars
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about this little
usb right here
and why for just a very
normal looking silver usb it costs
more than 10 grand the answer is very
simple and it's because it is an
archicad
license dongle it costs 10 grand to
acquire one of these usbs to be able to
run the software however this isn't your
only option because you can very quickly
and very very easily lose this little
usb here
and you've lost yourself 10 grand so
today let's talk about all the different
licensing options that you have right
now in 2020
the end of 2020 almost 2021 for archicad
24 and moving into the future okay so
obviously
you have the very expensive dongle that
you don't really want to be throwing
around like i did
it can break it can damage very easily
it is
their hardware key option it is a
physical device
you can plug it into your computer
anywhere you go and you automatically
have a license
you don't need the internet to connect
to anything you don't need any sort of
remote connection
you literally plug it in wait for the
light to go green
disappear and you're good to go now
there are a couple shortfalls
with the hardware key option obviously
it's a physical key
it's very small it's just the standard
usb that you can lose
very easily if you throw it up in the
air you can probably damage it if you
don't catch it
if somebody comes along whacks it out of
your computer again you can damage it
somebody can easily steal this i don't
know why they probably wouldn't know
what it is
but they could steal the usb out of your
car if you left it or from your home
so that's definitely an option that
results in this key
being even more expensive than it
already is the other downside is a
simple fact that it is still
usb-a so i don't know if you guys can
see this
i'll do some b-roll on it but basically
it's still
usb-a if you need a usb-c option
there is very minimal options out there
from graphisoft to be able to supply you
with a usb-c hardware key
all the new macs coming in a usbc even
the surface pros coming in at usbc
most of the desktops are even converting
to usbc
so this little guy is probably going to
be obsolete very very quickly
until they start rolling out more usbc
options
now i think i said usbc there about 10
times so apologies for that another
shortfall is the simple fact that you
just forget
so for example this guy usually lives at
my office 24 7.
i leave it plugged into my desktop and i
forget about it
however as ever since covert started i'm
either working from home more
or i'm traveling a lot more and doing my
work on the road so for me
i'm starting to take this thing
everywhere with me
it's become habitual now so i finish the
day unplug it put it on my keyring and
move on but at the start i used to
forget it all the time
and that's what led me to creating this
video today you do have a secondary
option
which is available as well and that is
the software key version so the software
key version
sounds great in theory but it has its
pros and cons as well
what the software key version is is
basically a downloadable
license key it means when you connect to
the internet
you can download that key from the cloud
directly to your computer
however the issue there being is that
once you've finished using that key
you have to release it back to the cloud
if you don't release it back to the
cloud and you jump onto another computer
it's literally the same problem you had
before
where you forgot your little dongle so
if you have a good memory
and you're not going to forget to
release that key it's
definitely a better option and a much
safer one
if you're running a large office on the
other hand that has many staff members
some of which you can't rely on or some
of which you just
don't want to take the chance with well
then
having a software key might be a bigger
problem because
you could have 100 licenses and 110
staff for example
only 100 would ever be on archicad at
any given time
however 20 of those people are
unreliable and always forget
to re-upload their key to the cloud this
means more often than not you're going
to have some of your staff members
unable to access archicad that is an
issue because
staff members not working means staff
members not making you money
so that's where the hardware key has the
advantage if it's always plugged into
the computer
it's never lost it's always ready to go
the software key isn't
exactly as simple as just plug and play
either there is a little bit of it setup
involved and required to be able to run
a software key
for an office large or small so for
example if you have a software key
you're more than likely going to want to
host it on one single computer that has
an uninterrupted power source
and uninterrupted internet source
because the second you lose power
or the second you lose internet you no
longer have access to those licenses
it's hosted on that one computer which
can distribute to anybody around the
world that has internet access
your licenses can be borrowed from the
cloud which is a good thing
if you don't have internet access and
you're going out remote somewhere
a couple hundred k's into the desert you
still need to use archicad you can
borrow that license
not worry about wi-fi and just keep
working so
that's that's not really here nor there
the issue becomes that you need a
secondary machine sitting somewhere in
the office
like the old host server computers for
example
that literally just sits there and runs
cloud software
nevertheless both options are going to
cost you the same amount of money to
license
archicad is a proprietary program that
requires you to pay the price
for the good software that's not what
we're really talking about today though
the two licensing options have their
pros and cons
personally speaking i still think that
the hardware key
is the better option hence why i'm still
holding
a 10 000 usb my personal opinion i
believe that
making people remember to take something
with them
is a lot easier and a lot more
convenient
than having to rely on a constant power
support constant
internet connection and basically
uninterrupted i.t issues we all live in
a world where we know that is
never going to happen i.t issues are a
problem all the time
internet dropouts happen more often than
not power is
definitely out of your control if you
have a laptop the power goes out oh well
you just keep working until your laptop
dies you'll probably get an extra two or
three hours of productivity in so yeah
that's why i personally believe that the
usb option is
still the better option in 2020
maybe one day we're going to have a much
easier system where it's all already
hosted with graphisoft
you don't have to worry about it they do
all the monitoring you just
sign into your company username password
download the key
away you go but until that day
the 10 000 usb is the way to go anyways
that's all from me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
the video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button to help with the youtube
algorithm
and smash that subscribe button if you
want to see more of my content